Sharon Gannon of course I'm not sure
where I was born but my parents told me
that I was born in georgetown university
hospital Washington DC that's our
nation's capital and I was born at dawn
on july 4th in my early my early
childhood oh we lived in in DC and my
dad was a racecar driver so at one point
when I was about three we moved to
Florida to be near Daytona Beach and
that really didn't last long his
ambitions kind of fizzled out and we
went back to DC and but then they
separated and I moved with my mother to
various places we lived on a farm in
West Virginia then we moved to Tucson
Arizona and I grew up during my high
school years in seattle washington which
I love before I moved to New York I
thought I'd be a poet I don't know if
that's a profession but it's always been
kind of the filter from which I've seen
and acted through I was suffering a very
traumatic experience in my very early
20s and previous to that I mean I was I
was a bookworm and I was very not
connected to my body my physical body
and so this drama happened and um it
really it was a very severe shake up and
to make a long story short I tried to
kill myself and um my sister actually
saved me and my sister saved me and I
was trying to do it in a very bizarre
way falling in front of
cars during rush hour traffic she saw me
from bedroom window and ran down to
where I was and slapped me and said what
do you think you're doing you know I was
like oh my god I wouldn't kill myself
I'm just no good in blah blah blah blah
and she goes she and she was only 19 and
she said something so mature for a 19
year old woman it's my younger sister
even she said if someone had hit you and
had killed you how do you think the rest
of their life would be how do you think
that would impact on them for the rest
of their life and at that moment that
pushed me out of myself involved woe is
me I'm no good bubble and I realized
something about myself about all of us
and that was that everything that we do
impacts everyone around us and so
because of that incident I made a
conscious decision wow I better pull
myself together and try to find some way
to live in a way that perhaps I could
contribute something of benefit to
others and because I was physically a
wreck a friend of my sisters who was a
dance student at the University of
Washington I lived in Seattle suggested
you know why don't you take a summer
dance ballet workshop they have they
give these things for non matriculated
students adult students it might do you
some good so I actually did and studied
with an incredible teacher Ruth Anna
Boris who was a balancing
answer and I mean I was really the worst
person in the class you know I was 21
years old and I mean I really could not
tell my left from my right and um but I
knew that if I was going to have a
positive effect upon others that I
couldn't be this shattered shy you know
anorexic afraid of my own shadow type of
a person I had to had to claim my body I
had to claim my life in a way that then
I could perhaps contribute in some way
to the happiness of others